i think a lot of people have very strong
thoughts on this
and you know we don't talk about it
enough i want to talk about the concept
of
making one's bed oh my god
this is where we're going with this okay
this is where we're going yep
pop culture and we talk about life and
this is one that's important
so this is so pathetic some people
make their bed and others don't and
actually we should look this up
okay most people do not do it um 37
percent of people say they make their
bed and then there's a
20 sometimes you're already you're
already doing you're already doing
two black and white because it's not
just do you make your bed or do you not
it's do your make do you make your bed
every single day do you make your bed
a lot of the time but not every day or
do you not make your bed
like those are sort of your categories
so i am on the side
of things where i'm on the sidewalk i
believe you should always make your bed
because here's why you're gonna
accomplish anything you have to
accomplish one thing first and making
your bed is first thing you accomplish
and then you can start accomplishing
other things and the other thing if you
have a rough day
you can come home and you got a nice
lovely made bed to be in
and there are certain people
particularly carly riley who think this
is illogical
i'm not like anti-making the bed here's
where the illogicalness comes in right
i do not like
accomplish less in my day because my bed
was not made
so that's where i say there's no actual
logical reason
to have to make your bed this is an
emotional response thing
that for some people works very well so
apparently for zachary
like he's just emotionally on a better
page if he knows the bed is made that's
where i come down so i would love to
know what other people think on this
do you make the bed every single day oh
and within the first 30 minutes because
if you make it like in the afternoon for
example
that's unacceptable we wake up get it
out of the way you make it a must it's
like brushing your teeth it's like
putting on deodorant it's just like a
part
no okay good logical there are
much more logical reasons to brush your
teeth and put on deodorant this is
exactly
where you and i start to disagree right
so brushing your teeth is
hygienic reasons you need to take care
of your teeth or they will fall out and
you won't be able to eat food and you'll
die at
40. right like like there are actual
reasons you need to brush your teeth
that are
very logical and about your own health
so sound off
team um come at us do you are you a bed
maker
are you every day or just
always sometimes rarely never yes um
always sometimes rarely never where are
you on the bed making stuff where are
you on the bed making
and i would like your comments if you do
support the making bed all the time
please let me know give me that
solidarity okay making the bed crew
people are to be like it's logical to
make your bed because like human
awesome no because like human reactions
are such that like oh yeah people are
involuntary that they feel good
not for me though i don't know i'm an
anomaly well i'll talk about shikari
richardson
um she is our best female runner in the
olympics
um upcoming olympics and she was
disqualified for the
from the olympics because she tested
positive for thc
or marijuana um and
it's been really interesting to me to
watch this
because people have come down
very strongly on one side so what i want
to do with like having things
and having topics on the show is when
people are like freaking out about
something like have a rational
conversation about it people have come
down very strongly on either side
um and i'm curious your thoughts carly
but it seems like this on one hand
um this is my sense of the argument on
one hand this is ridiculous she said she
was using i think she took a brownie
because she um
was grieving her grandmother um her
stepmother it was like
was it that's a figure yeah okay so
she's grieving
so on one hand like it's freaking
marijuana like uh
in addition like it's it's not actually
a performance enhancing drug if anything
it slows you down right so
um like this is ridiculous on one hand
fundamentally this is ridiculous rule
agree with i think i think most
people can agree with that unless you're
very anti-marijuana
on the other hand and i think that's
where eileen is that is what joe biden
said is that
um it is a rule like rules are rules um
and if you want to compete in the
olympics you have to follow the rules
they set even if they're stupid and
archaic
um they're not particularly
i don't know if you could argue if
they're harming you or not but they are
the rules you agreed to play by these
rules in order to run in the race i mean
people are very very strong and it's um
some of the comments been racially
fueled um which i understand
um i don't i love your thoughts carly
and then i guess i'll dive into my more
my opinion um
thoughts on the rule here and thoughts
on um
shikari's situation i think on the micro
level
i don't think there's there's racism at
play here and that this rule
would obviously have been i believe very
equally administered if it had been a
white player who had done this i think
he or she would be facing the same
punishment you and i have talked about
there's been examples in football and
other sports where you've had
white players punished for smoking
marijuana on the macro level
there's a very real question to be had
around
how much we've criminalized marijuana in
this country and in the world at large
as a way to specifically be able to
incarcerate black people you know like
on some level and so there is this
broader criminalizing marijuana thing
that
feels like it is racist and obviously
has been used
in very racist ways aoc called it racist
and colonial
yeah you know that again i i think
there's a macro argument to be made
there i think in this
specific instance i'm with you like
these are the rules
i have a ton of empathy for her though
being like look i'm human and i did this
and i'm i'm i'm surprised too i mean
presumably she was very aware of the
rules and
knew she was going to be tested so it
just goes to show how much pain she must
have been in and i really empathize with
that
i also will say like so in this this
particular case i don't think
like you know on that there's a micro
level racism here
uh relatedly though there's this whole
there's another controversy around
um the olympics banning certain swim
caps
that better fit black black women in
particular black black
people in general but because of their
hair and you had the olympic committee
saying like
oh these swim caps aren't the natural
shape of a human head
and therefore they're banned yeah and
that's clearly racist and insane and i
don't know where we'll end up on that i
mean i just
say clearly we need to allow these swim
caps to be used
um but i think those are two examples
where i come down sort of on different
different sides of them where i think
the the weed rule
again macro level there's there's
probably some racism there in our world
for sure
micro level in this particular instance
i don't think there's racism
specifically against shikari
swim cap rule crazy totally needs to
change and let's just let that i think
the
electric demonstrated that they're
bit behind the times a bit our character
a bit more i'm sure it's like a bunch of
white people like i you know i doubt
there's a lot of diversity on the
olympic
so if that's where asu's going i i
understand i do think like
if you're an olympic athlete you know
the rules um and so like i i'm i was a
josh gordon fan who was a receiver
who eventually got suspended and then
banned from the nfl
or number i think i guess multi-year
suspensions
close to banning um for frankly just
smoking too much wheat
um and he would do games like drunk and
high and still perform at a crazy elite
level
um but they banned him because those are
the rules
and i don't like agree like i think
players be able to smoke marijuana like
come on
um but that is the rule um so if you i
think everybody should be up in arms
about the rule they shouldn't be up in
their
arms about this decision about the rule
being applied fairly in this case
right yeah i agree now i don't know and
this is why i would say i don't know
enough instances
um about the racial component of this
have they
let white white athletes sneak through
the cracks on these or get more
exceptions i don't actually know
um given that they're old-school
conservative um
actually i don't know i don't know my
gut would say that might
that they're probably just generally
extremely strict um
but um i don't know i do feel for
that that sucks um this rule is horrific
horrific and frankly as an american like
damn it i wanted her to go with her
awesome hair and nails and kick
everybody's freaking ass
like that would have been the real
american thing was like yeah we sent we
sent shikari over there and
ran circles around you like hell yeah
and she can do it like looking amazing
um
so that was heartbreaking because i like
to see when we win that's like when i've
always loved that so
um frustrating um i know people have
takes you can comment us as well
last thing carl before we rock and roll
give me the free brittany update because
there is news there is news in the pop
culture world and you're my only source
i refuse to yeah i refuse to give it
more clicks
well you know we're we're trying to
straddle this line i'm not going to pop
culture
deep because i think i'm the only one
who really wants to know like who harry
styles is dating
it's like me and the buffalo bills just
gotta give him a taste yeah yeah well
and also
the brittany movement i think also
crosses into the legal world like
there's a lot that's interesting here
so there's basically kind of two there's
two updates i would say broadly umbrella
kind of updates there's
um what's happening with the
conservatorship and and the team
in place around the conservatorship
there's been some big moves there and
then there's sort of personal news
so this past week ronan farrow who quite
famously like busted open a lot of the
harvey weinstein stuff ronan and a
co-author at the new yorker
did a whole piece about the free
brittany situation
and they exposed a number of new details
for instance they
talked to a very close family friend of
the spears's
who has been present apparently
throughout this entire process
who says that very early on
after the conservatorship was put into
place she witnessed britney's father
like screaming at britney calling her a
fat [ __ ]
like being very verbally abusive towards
her um and that she had
previously been actually somewhat in
favor of the conservatorship and then
witnessed some of that saw some other
things and is now
very opposed to the conservatorship so
they exposed some sort of family
riffs and family details like that which
were honestly all very heartbreaking
then there's big news on the conservator
side so the the judge
in this case in the current case um
ruled against
uh moving jamie spears britney's father
out of the conservatorship so jamie is
remaining a conservator um
now that that's not about whether the
conservatorship will end or not
that will be a separate but it's more
like who is the conservator however
um the judge did put a second
conservator in place to
manage her finances with jamie and
that's this bessemer trust this
professional
trust group that that does this often
for different clients
what's fascinating is that the day after
essentially bessemer trust was put in
place as the conservator with jamie
spears
they asked to be removed and
as details have emerged it sounds like
when they were initially
approached to be the co-conservator of
this estate
they were approached by a man named sam
ingram i believe who's britney spears
attorney and sam had told them that this
conservatorship was voluntary and that
britney was
fine with it and that that's why
bessemer trust had agreed to sign on and
be this co-conservator
and that after they heard britney's own
testimony in court
it was made clear to them that this was
very much not voluntary that brittany
very much wanted out of it
and so now bessemer trust wants out of
being a co-conservator
so they were misled and this is what's
very interesting by brittany's own
attorney
which feeds this whole broader narrative
right now that that sam
brittany's attorney is actually much
closer to jamie spears and despite being
britney's attorney is actually working
for a conservator more than he's working
for her
so the drama just continues the bottom
line is jamie spears will remain
conservative for the time being
but other conservators are trying to
drop out britney's
talent manager just quit um and said he
doesn't believe brittany's going to
return to performing basically anytime
soon and so he doesn't need him
um and that she's probably in a
permanent retirement
so bad news for the britney fans
[Music]
you